i think magnus wants to get to 36. i
mean they could break the world record
here they could if they hadn't pushed
those pawns they could wait 50 moves
then push upon wait 50 moves and push
another pawn
maybe they're waiting until year 40 and
then they can actually offer the draw
yeah
beautiful cemetery with the pawns and
now with the kings as well oh here it
comes now there's an invitation we'll
just move back and forth back and forth
and this is where actually playing
online it's difficult you don't want to
pre-move you don't want to just put your
rook on the wrong square because your
opponent could guess which square you're
going to put your rook and then they'll
capture your rook but of course offline
over the board there won't be any
blunders now and now 100 moves less than
end the world record game yesterday yeah
and this is the second time we've seen
that position with black's king on the
g7 square and the white rook on b5 and
they'll just repeat once more i think
it's going to be 38 moves
with black's next move he can indeed
claim a draw if he wants to
will magnus do that or will he just play
until move 40. okay why bother calling
the arbiter when uh
you can just play the moves get to move
40 and they are allowed officially to
offer that draw
and uh here we go another three-fold
repetition both players smiling
nice touch there yeah will they at all
discuss this game or is it not even
interesting to them i think they'll
shrug their shoulders and smile at each
other
42 i guessed 42 moves today i did two
kaya and a jewel
and a royal lopez okay oh hi i know have
they even agreed yet have they shaken
hands we haven't seen that yet there we
go
game seven in dubai we're halfway and it
is a draw the magnus then still leads